rich people the 1% everyone loves the 1%
right guess where they all are and it's
the fastest place that they're growing
yeah Washington DC that's right let's
look at some some facts about the
growing population of rich people in DC
during the past decade the region added
21,000 households in the nation's top 1%
no other metro area came even close
companies spent about 3.5 billion
annually on lobbying at the end of the
last decade a nearly 90 percent increase
from 1999 and of course all the
lobbyists work and most of them live in
the DC area so before we get to the
nitty-gritty of this should this
surprised anybody with everything going
on in the country that the 1% is a that
it's growing but not as a growing it's
growing of course in Washington DC no I
mean money is the thing there I mean it
has been especially the last 20 years
and I think of the thing I found most
fascinating about this was that they
were talking about because of the the
government investment in the region and
the the stimulus package that this
wealth has come there so I'm like so
government investment in a actually work
so it's weird so it works in that right
so it works for the government people
right yes it works in general you know
it creates jobs and it's created a lot
of jobs it's it's just the jobs that are
there a little frightening yeah what's
interesting because you know Washington
has always been about power rather than
money and this article was so
interesting and it's kind of a lengthy
article and encourage everyone to read
it cuz it's just so interesting showing
how the money especially after 9/11 we
allotted a lot of money towards
everything whether it be security
beefing up government have anything in
the government you wanted to do we kind
of said ok like just keep us safe so all
this money got poured in and then in
turn you have what used to be it being
about power and control in the
government you have younger people you
have smarter people more educated people
going to Washington and working for
these firms and it's interesting cuz if
you lived in DC I remember my sister
went to school there she after it
graduated and worked for a consulting
firm and the whole thing was if he
worked on K Street that was where all
the money was and outside of that you
were a government employee right and you
made a decent but modest wage and you
weren't flashy there certainly wasn't
like a Tesla dealership exactly it's
interesting to see the shift in
Washington I feel like it's also a
cultural shift in mirroring or maybe
it's chicken or egg kind of what's going
on with America where the power is now
through money through showing you have
money through showing you can buy
something well speaking of how power is
through money so let's look at some
numbers about the 1% and how money
breaks down in general I'm really
fascinated by this so if you're in the
top 1% you make roughly three hundred
eighty thousand dollars a year I think
when people think of a 1% they think
that means you're like mr. burns
billions but free a lot of money no it's
not and then you can see the rest of the
numbers there but top 10% you're making
around 113 thousand which if you live in
a metro area in New York or in
California or even in DC but that's
really not that much money and then
you're the top 50% if you make thirty
three thousand I don't even want to tell
you what percentage I'm in because we'll
all cry but the disparity though the
income disparity is still huge even if
you know three hundred and eighty
thousand dollars doesn't seem like a lot
to get into the 1% from there the sky's
the limit the other people in the 1%
might also have 3 billion and those
people are not even in the same world of
what they can't afford but they can do
with their money and turning it into
wealth and then the people making 33
thousand you know they can't write even
get food in their mouth right and that's
the majority of the country so to that
point should we be talking about
something different than the 1% because
if we're talking on the 1% of course 300
something thousand dollars is a nice
amount of money and you can have a
politician not even really you can live
a wealthy life I don't regret anyone
that has wealth that's great but
shouldn't we be talking shouldn't there
be some other number that we don't meant
like if you make over 5 million or point
zero zero one percent a minute I've
heard that term abandoned which probably
means you make let's say a million I
have no idea but in Washington DC is
what they're trying to show is that
Washington DC and the amount of people
and the amount of money they're pouring
into it is kind of turning Washington
into the new Hollywood so basically
they're recruiting people that are going
to now be you know people that make the
$300,000 now they're not individually
influence in Washington instead they
have about 20 of them or 50 of these
people making
thousand dollars working at one firm and
collectively they're now putting in
enough money they're encouraging
different businesses to put 26 billion
or million or whatever it is into
influence in Washington and one thing in
the story that was important to look at
was that one woman who is talking about
how she was recruited to explain the
companies to how to show them how to
make the to get deregulation of handling
hazardous waste to get Congress to
deregulate that so a company can make
more money she only makes 300 thousand
dollars a year but she just influenced a
you know company billions of dollars in
cuts for policies for company and then
it completely affects everyone in
America because you know toxic waste is
not being handled properly so yeah is
this also proof that the Republicans and
the Democrats are just the same freakin
thing because we have a Democratic
administration right now so you'd think
that that's more for the people but what
we're seeing is actually the one percent
keep growing and everybody because I
mean I think everyone signed on for a
while that you know corporate money is
the engine of our economy you know and
that's it and it happened when Clinton
you know when he cut the welfare state
and he made a big deal with
communications corporations the
Communications Act completely
deregulated media which is you know
created what we have now in media which
is a bunch of [ __ ] and so you know I
mean you know when Clinton came around
toward the middle that that's what it is
that that is you know America is
capitalism it is about big business and
and and that is the business in
government these days but the other
aspect of the story that freaked me out
a little bit was that a lot of the money
coming in is due to the security
contractors because it that went you
know exploded after 9/11 so now it's
kind of a Silicon Valley innovation kind
of place but the innovation all is
around security and privacy issues and
you know and and all the cyber stuff and
that freaks me out because the more
money that's invested in that more
people are invested in keeping the money
they're keeping these security policies
in place and it's like the industrial
war complex we need a war every now and
again so that they can keep the money
going
you see what's interesting is that the
war is kind of internal now and on us
because they were showing that defense
contract spending has gone way down and
like you're saying the IT spending is
going way up so now rather than it being
beneficial to us to wage war in the
Middle East or somewhere else it's
beneficial to wage war against your own
citizens in
monitor them because like you were
saying now we have to keep all these
people employed and then we have to
justify their employment
so forget sending people overseas
building ships bombs submarine you know
forget that technology now it's all
about biotechnology and NSA yeah
justifying us well we're gonna get to
that in the story later so one more
number I want to throw out of you guys
and then one last question so the top 1%
rose 19.6% last year compared with a 1%
increase for the remaining 99% so that
sort of tells you that the game is
stacked against us you know what this
was reminding me of my favorite bit that
your father did about how there's a club
and we're not and I and you know we're
gonna post a link to the to the article
that we got this from and I'll post a
link to the to the clip from your bed
but that's what was making me feel like
there is just this thing out there this
giant money thing yeah and if you really
think about it and think of it in terms
of a club that you can't get in you
start to think well screw it you know
like what can I do to make it different
so how can I change this this is just
the machine and it's part of it it's
despair yeah if I'm not in the club I'm
never going to be so I might as well
just put my head down and work and get
the little piece of pie that I can so
that was my last question and then what
do you suppose how do you take a story
like this and then feel okay about it
well beyond just putting your head down
and it does create a despair inside of
the average person in this country but I
think also like you know you look at the
Occupy Wall Street movement and the one
thing that they did do is they did
create this conversation that we're
having right now about the 1% so there
is an awareness at least in the
consciousness of citizens whether the
average person feels they can do
anything about it maybe not but there
are people who feel compelled and really
do live to fight the system and you know
so there is a conversation going on on
some level and you know it is it's I it
fills me with a bit of a disparar it
does it's like how are we supposed to
fight against then it was really good
way to fight against this is exactly
what you said though look people say
Occupy Wall Street was a failure or
disappeared yeah but it's made the 1%
now the term the 1% existed before but
not nobody it wasn't a mainstream term
everyone whose decision wasn't being
exactly yeah it's used as a noun as a
verb it's just everyone understands what
the 1% is where the average of
can definitely did not understand that
there was one person I didn't understand
the term or how to apply it so I think
in the end when you're asking how you
fight it it's just information it's like
when you were talking about deregulation
of media most people here at
deregulation and think well that's great
and that really depends on you know your
endgame and how and how you think about
stuff but people don't understand that
also means that corporations are able to
come in and tell you what information
you're getting so it's really about
being its personal responsibility and
keeping yourself informed and I think
that's the way to avoid despair just by
saying I'm gonna take personal
responsibility Wow Jen Hoffman bringing
this to a place that I feel slightly
empowered you know it as they as guy
fawkes said in V for Vendetta you can
kill a man but not an idea so use that
for something